>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Welcome to the Library
of Congress.
[Inaudible] for all.
Welcome, welcome, to the
historic Coolidge Auditorium,
the Library of Congress
After Hours.
It's going to be a
really good panel.
So to introduce myself,
my name is Sasha Dowdy.
I work here at the library
as program specialist
at the Young Readers Center.
So I do programming for
kids who are under 16,
but sometimes I do
programming for kids over 16.
So that's why we're all here.
We have had a series of
events in conjunction
with Otakon here at the library.
So we're really excited
to present
to you a very, very
special guest.
And now we're going to have a
panel with two library staff,
and they're going to speak to
an incredible person that we're
so excited to have here:
Mister Hirokatsu Kihara.
He's a writer and
producer formally involved
with the production
desk at Studio Ghilbi ,
and he was involved in the
hit anime such as "Laputa:
Castle in the Sky," and
"My Neighbor Totoro,"
and "Kiki's Delivery Service."
Any fans of these
movies in here?
[ Applause ]
So now he writes ghost stories,
and he MCs at monster
conventions.
So there's a lot going on here.
His most famous work is "Tales
of Terror: Haunted Apartment."
So -- And he's been
a crucial contributor
to many other hits in the genre.
And he's going to be interviewed
by two library staff members.
Maureen Cohen Harrington.
She's a senior counsel
in the library's office
of the general counsel.
That's lawyers.
And she feels fortunate
that her law gig allows her
to explore and expand interests.
She has an undergrad degree
in radio, television, film,
and has been to many comic
and pop culture conventions.
So when she's not here,
she's at San Diego Comic-Con
and Awesome Con and on and on.
She's kind of new to anime so
she is going to learn about it
as she talks with her coworker
in general counsel's office,
Anthony Dunn, where
he goes by Ant.
He is a lover of food,
design, cool socks,
anime, and all things nerdy.
So he's one of us.
They're both fans of pop
culture, and inline skating,
and they discover
lots of new things.
And, in the spirit of Library
of Congress being an institution
of learning, we're all going to
learn something new together.
So let's welcome Mister
Kihara, Maureen, and Ant.
Come on out.
[ Applause ]
>> Anthony Dunn:
Hello, everyone.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Hello.
>> Hirokatsu Kihara: Hello.
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington: Hi.
Welcome. And welcome to
the Library of Congress.
We are very honored
to have you here.
>> Hirokatsu Kihara:
Nice to meet you.
>> Maureen Cohen: And we
are glad you were able
to take a tour of the
library before our event now.
What do you think
of our library?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: First let
me introduce myself.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I want to
thank Otakon and the Library
of Congress for having
me here today.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I'm truly
grateful that I was able
to meet everybody today.
Thanks to them, I'm very happy.
Okay. Now ask me anything.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Well,
what do you think
of the library?
What did you think of
what you saw today?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: Great.
[ Laughter ]
>> Hirokatsu Kihara: Amazing.
Marvelous.
Fantastic.
>> Speaker 2: It's unbelievable.
You never see this
kind of thing in Japan.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: The powers
of books made in to art.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I was very moved.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> Speaker 2: You guys --
You don't know how
great you have it.
>> Anthony Dunn: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington:
I loved watching when you went
to the main reading room.
You just looked up.
It was so beautiful to watch.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: He read about this
place when he was very little.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: He looked at
the pictures of this building,
and said he wanted to
visit this place one day.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: He never
imagined, and is truly surprised
that the first time
he's here he's on stage.
[ Applause ]
It took 50 years,
you know to get here.
It was my goal.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: He's very honored
to be here, to meet everybody.
Okay. How about anime questions?
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington: Oh.
Anime. Yes.
Yes. Okay.
>> Anthony Dunn: First
of all, we're honored
to have you here, Mister Kihara.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington:
So, for anime questions, I'm --
Unlike Anthony, I
am new to anime.
So where do you start?
What -- As I am just
learning for the first time,
what in your words, in
other people's words,
do you think is a good
thing to see or to study
or to enter this world?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I think it's true
for everybody that you want
to see something that's
made in your own country.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I think that you
should see what people
in your country have made.
Walt Disney's, you know,
"Steamboat Willie," [inaudible]
and Betty Boop and Popeye.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
It's created for kids, but
not by children, of course.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Grown ups made something
for the children.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I think it's the best to
see something that was made
for children in your
own country.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
If you think that's
amazing, the next step is
to see something
from other countries.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Definitely it is I grew
up on Disney cartoons.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Really?
>> Speaker 2: I loved
the [inaudible] brothers.
I think it's the same
as everybody, right?
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington: So
what about your work, though?
When we're ready to move
to your work or if we want
to just skip a step
and go there,
what would your favorite be?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: This year's
the 30th anniversary
of 30th anniversary of "Totoro."
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: April 16, 1988 was
when it came out
in the theaters.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
It's truly an honor to come
here to D.C on that special year
to talk about "Totoro."
You know, the place that I
had imagined since childhood.
I was 28 years old at the time.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[Inaudible] told
me, "You can do it.
Let's make Totoro together."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
The making of "Totoro," you
know the inside information
[inaudible] of "Totoro,"
the movie, is going to come
out on September 4th as a book.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
It hasn't actually been
announced yet in Japan
so I think it's a miracle
that I can talk about it
in a library, of all places.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Wow.
You heard it here first.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I think that --
I feel that I was born
to be doing this today.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
It's really an honor that I can
be here in front of everybody,
and say the word "Totoro."
Ask me anything.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Okay.
So you started to
talk about this a bit.
What is your origin story?
What led you down
this career path?
Either personal experiences
or artistic, cultural,
historical influences?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I just watched
a lot of TV when I was little.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: We all do.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: Then I started
to read books and manga.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I think it's true for everybody,
but I started to get curious
about how is this made.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And then I started to think that
I wanted to be part of that too,
and bring joy to everybody.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I went through phases when
I was little that I wanted
to create movies, I
wanted to create manga,
and I wanted to write.
All those things.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
At one point I wanted to create
[inaudible] and "Godzilla."
And then my friend Anno Hideaki
finally created "Godzilla."
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: And then when I
was eight years old I watched
"Horus, Price of the
Sun" by Isao Takahata
and Hayao Miyazaki, and
I wanted to become --
join the animation industry.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I worked hard so that
I could work side by side
with these great people.
And then, 20 years
later, it came true.
>> Hirokatsu Kihara:
Don't give up.
[ Applause ]
>> Anthony Dunn:
So you said you --
How'd you meet Mister Miyazaki?
Like did you -- You said you
worked hard to get there.
So how did you like, you
know, actually meet him?
And become a member
of Studio Ghilbi.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: So I joined
[inaudible] a company,
the studio that created
"Nausicaa
of the Valley of the Wind."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I didn't join because it
was making "Nausicaa,"
but because it was a company
that was producing animation
in collaboration with
the United States.
Have you ever heard of Topcraft?
Topcraft?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I used to -- It's a studio
that created animation for the
"Hobbit" and "The Last Unicorn."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Also [inaudible] who was
a producer at the time.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
They were working
in collaboration
with Topcraft in Japan.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
When I was in high school
I took a studio tour,
and I wanted to --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But then Hayo Miyazaki liked
me, and then we made "Nausicaa."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Then I graduated college, and
then officially joined Topcraft.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But a year and a half later
this studio collapsed.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And then the president of
the studio at the time said
that we were making this
movie called "Nausicaa."
So please, you know,
work on that.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[Inaudible] is the --
[Inaudible] is the person,
the president, of
Ghibli at the time.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So he was boss of -- my boss
at the time at Topcraft.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So he said that, "I saw
your work at Topcraft,
and admire your endurance
and your fighting spirit."
And he thought that he
could control Miyazaki.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
It sounds unbelievable,
but I really wanted to work
with Miyazaki so I showed
up to work every single day.
The very first one in office,
and left after the
very last person.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Wow.
>> Anthony Dunn: Wow.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: So I told
myself, "Hard work.
Hard work.
Hard work."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[Inaudible] Miyazaki
told [inaudible]
"Don't let this guy quit."
And he had to make
this guy keep going.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
At the time he didn't know why.
And then one day he patted me on
the shoulder and turned around,
and he -- Miyazaki was there.
>> Hirokatsu Kihara: What?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: And he told
me, "You and I are going
to make Totoro together."
And that is how "Totoro"
was made 30 years ago.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
After making "Castle in the
Sky," they were producing
"Grave of the Fireflies."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I don't know if you guys
noticed, but "Totoro" and "Grave
of the Fireflies" was
shown as a double feature.
"Grave of the Fireflies"
started production first.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But it was good that when
we started working --
I started working with Miyazaki,
but then the studio
told us to leave.
>> Hirokatsu Kihara: Get out.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: Because they had
to use the studio to produce
"Grave of the Fireflies"
so they told us to leave,
and build a new studio.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So we're doing a long history
of Ghibli during this
production stage of "Totoro"
and "Grave of the Fireflies."
There were two studios.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
"Totoro" was created in this --
the second studio that was
only created for that time.
And after "Totoro" it
was consolidated back
in to a single studio again.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And that was "Kiki's
Delivery Service."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So if you have a special
fondness for "Totoro,"
that was born under
special circumstances.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So you can imagine how insane
it was to be producing "Totoro"
and "Grave of the
Fireflies" at the same time.
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington: Is
there a character that you --
You are so animated yourself
that I can see why you
are drawn to animation.
Is there a character who
you relate with most closely
or feel the most bonded?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Yours or someone else's.
>> Speaker 2: Yes.
Always laughing all
the time in the studio.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And then became the
model for the cat voice.
[ Screeching ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: Hayao Miyazaki
told me that his happiness is
to be laughing and running.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But saying you're sad when
you're sad, and being upset
when you're upset doesn't
really change anything.
Then why don't we just
laugh with everybody?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Being able to laugh at
work will bring you hope.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
We were rushed in production.
We were not making
anything on time.
We had to do all this painting,
and nothing was being
made on time, but --
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And then we would
all get together and,
okay, it's thinking time.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
They say that when
you're laughing,
then you can create
better ideas.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
There's only a 10 day
[inaudible] between completion
of "Castle in the Sky"
and release to theaters.
10 days. 10 days.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
"Totoro" there were only 15 days
between drawing every
single piece of art
and release in to theaters.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Other studios kept thinking,
"You're not going
to make it on time."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But Takahata, he's like,
"You do not give up."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
The desire to create
something great,
they refused to cut corners.
That's why they tried hard.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
If you're making a sad
face, that's not the kind
of movie that you want to see.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
You have to grit your
teeth, and just laugh.
[Inaudible] making
this for children.
>> Like in skating where
you look where you're going.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I tripped on it.
I had a fall.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So there are 75,000 in between
[inaudible] pieces of art
in "Castle in the
Sky" hand drawn.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
That means 75,000 individual
pieces of [inaudible]
that got painted by hand.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And that was -- This was
all completed in 10 months.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And this is incredible work.
It's all hand drawn.
Not digital.
There was no software back then.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Unimaginable.
Clicking, you know,
each person that had
to be hand photographed.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
People who give up
can't do animation.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So people who love animation
are people who don't give up.
So that's why he has --
They have his respect.
That is true for everybody here.
[ Applause ]
>> Anthony Dunn: So what was
your favorite movie to work at,
work on, at Studio Ghibli?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: "Castle
in the Sky" was --
created the most hardship
for everybody, though.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
"Kiki's Delivery
Service" was the one
that had the hardest schedule,
and everybody had to, you know,
be rushing from the start.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
"Totoro" looks so fun on screen,
but in the very beginning
Miyazaki gave me one order.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
This is a fun movie.
You have to be having
fun making it.
That is my only order to you.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I felt that somebody had
to be, you know, smiling
and laughing somewhere
in this idea.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I mean that's an ideal, but
it's hard to do when you --
You know, it's a tough schedule.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But I think it was
possible just for "Totoro."
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
"Castle in the Sky" was tough
because I had to manage a studio
at the same time as
working on the production.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
"Kiki's" was behind schedule
from the very beginning.
So that's why it was tough.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I think it's amazing that
Miyazaki continues to be loved
around the world after 30 years.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Because I never gave up,
and always worked hard,
the result is that I'm here
today in front of all of you.
And grateful to every
single one of you.
[ Applause ]
>> Anthony Dunn: So what
made you leave Studio Ghibli?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: That
is a tough question.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So it was "Kiki's" that
finally became profitable.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Financially, "Castle in
the Sky" was not a success.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
It just wasn't a failure.
But Kiki's was a big success.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And sold a lot of laser disks
which was unknown at the time.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
When a studio becomes
financially profitable,
it attracts a lot of people.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And they don't necessarily
love the medium.
>> Hirokatsu Kihara: It's money.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: It becomes hard
to work when there's a lot
of people who don't feel love
for what they're creating.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I'd become like a
hindrance to the people
who were trying to make money.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Because I'm thinking about the,
you know -- every single worker.
I want to be on the side of
the staff and the director.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
For people on the
business side of things,
that's not necessarily
a good thing.
That's why I left.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Before that, I had to
manage the schedules
and audio of 200 people.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I just wanted to take
care of myself from then on.
And that's how I
became a writer.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So then since a lot of animists
use new media, they started
to call on me for
uncredited help
with various stages
of production.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So [inaudible] first --
Eventually they went on
to create [inaudible]
but on the first
animated they worked on,
I did a lot of work for them.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And there was also a
movie called "Gundam F91"
which I did a lot of work on to
get them to release on schedule.
I just told them
to not credit me.
I didn't want it.
Because I got my, you know,
fame through Miyazaki.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Because if I put my name
out there, then there's only
like three other people
who don't get their
work appreciated.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I shouldn't take their,
you know, spot [inaudible].
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So it looks like my work
in animation just stopped
after I left Ghibli.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But there's a lot of people
in the animation
industry right now who,
you know, started work with me.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So I'm very happy that so many
of my friends are still
continuing in making anime
in the industry right now.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
There's a movie right now called
"In the Corner of this World."
Mister Katabuchi used to work on
-- On "Kiki's Delivery Service?"
He was an assistant director.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And the super hit "Your Name,"
the art director for that work,
Mister [inaudible] was one
of the very first people
who got hired by Ghibli.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
It was "Code Geass."
Ever heard of "Code Geass?"
>> Anthony Dunn: Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I personally chose
Mister [inaudible] who worked
on "Code Geass," and he --
hand picked him to
be working on Ghibli.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So all these seeds that were
planted along the way has been
[inaudible] to find trees,
and he's very proud of that.
[ Applause ]
>> Anthony Dunn: Did you work
on the animation of "Code Geass"
or just the entire story?
>> Speaker 2: He's just
introducing the people
who worked on it for working
at Ghibli at the time,
who were working on these
other different works.
He can answer that.
Personally [inaudible].
>> Anthony Dunn: Tell us
about your book series,
the "Tales of Tokyo
and All of Japan."
How -- What was your
inspiration behind it,
to start like writing
this series, ghost series?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: He was a scaredy
cat when he was little."
Every little thing
he'd get spooked at.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
There wasn't as much, you know,
very brightening
things back then.
So it was very dark.
Buildings and houses
were very old.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So just like "Totoro," there
were these strange things
in the corner of your vision.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Like these glowing
things suddenly appeared,
and then disappeared
in to the wall.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I was working on "Castle in
the Sky" and I was driving
down the street at 3 AM.
It was 3 AM, and pitch black.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And in the cross walk ahead
of him there was a
kindergartner walking
across the street wearing
the stereotypical yellow hat
that kindergartners wear
with a yellow satchel.
On the knees and below.
[ Roar ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So you can experience
these things even
when you're growing up.
So I took these mysterious
things,
and put them in to books.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
These aren't made up stories.
They're all true
life experiences.
Including mine.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
People made fun of
me at the time,
but there are 100
stories like this.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
When I made 10 books
in the series,
to a total of 1,000 stories,
everybody was amazed.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I think I put down
2,600 stories total.
[Inaudible] mysterious things.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But just like, you
know, the art for anime,
you have to leave these stories
behind when they are going
to disappear and nobody's
going to hear about them.
Somebody has to leave them
for the next generation.
People can make fun of me, but
I still have to write them.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
People may not believe
me, but I really have --
You're obligated to leave
them for the next generation.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
You know, in my books
there are included stories
from California and
Hawaii as well.
Scary. America is really scary.
[ Laughter ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Oh, he went to the
Winchester Manor.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
He went up Mount
Shasta five times.
Crystal Geyser.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Very mysterious.
He likes going to places of
nature rather than places
that have a lot of people.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
There's something that I have
in common with Mister Miyazaki.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Thank you.
So we wanted to make sure
there's time for audience Q
and A. So we'll allow
Anthony one more question,
and then we'll turn it
over to the audience,
and I think we're
using that mic.
>> Anthony Dunn: You know,
here to ask some
questions for the audience.
I don't want to take
up too much time.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Yeah.
We could have like a long list
of questions, but you given
such wonderful detailed
answers that, you know,
we want to make sure that we
don't hog all of your time.
>> Anthony Dunn: So anyone
in the audience, do you --
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington:
If anyone has a question,
jut raise your hand.
We have one over there.
Are we -- How does this work?
Oh. Sasha will do it.
Thank you.
>> Speaker 3: I teach
so I'm very loud.
So how did you collect
these stories?
Did you have people helping you
or did you just go
out and collect?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 3: How did you
collect these stories?
Did you go out and gather them?
Did you have people
helping you collect them?
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Okay. You'd have to become
friends to hear these stories.
The basics of hearing ghost
stories is communication.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
The important thing is
communication, and you have
to approach people with an
open mind, and an open heart,
and say, "Did you
experience anything strange
when you were growing up?"
Or otherwise people
don't tell you.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I feel that I had success in
Ghibli because I had heart
to heart talks with people.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I feel like I was being able
to learn how to communicate
with grown ups by going
around asking grown ups
for their ghost stories,
and that's how I became good
at communicating
with other people.
And that's how I became able
to work with Mister Miyazaki.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
The important thing with
everything is communication.
You have to start
by becoming friends.
Starting from today,
everybody's a friend of mine.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
My biggest goal in coming
to Otakon was to talk about
"Totoro," but my other
goal is to make friends.
It was the same in Anime Boston.
It's the same everywhere.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
The word otaku doesn't
exactly mean peace.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But Otaku can only become
real in places of peace.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
In places of strife,
there are no otaku.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So places -- You
know, a convention
that calls themselves
a [inaudible]
of otaku looks really
shining and sparkling to me.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
If you don't get
along with somebody,
something you might
have in common is
that you love "Totoro."
Let's say we're not friends.
But I love her.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
If we have her in common,
we can become friends too.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
That is the wonderfulness
of something like anime.
You can love something in common
so you can become friends too.
Otaku is awesome.
>> Anthony Dunn: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Do we have another question?
>> Speaker 4: Hayao Miyazaki
published a collection
of his sketches in various
universes he imagined
as the daydream data notes.
Do you plan on ever publishing
a similar kind of collection?
>> Speaker 2: Who
was publishing?
>> Speaker 4: it
was Hayao Miyazaki.
He published.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: I don't draw.
But I have kept some records.
I have kept a lot of things that
people at the studio were going
to discard as trash
or recycling.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
These days studios do keep all
of their resources and pieces
of paper, but back then the
end goal was to create a piece
of film, and so all the
pieces of paper was trash.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Because there's no storage
space, just like this library.
So when things accumulate
you have to toss them out.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I felt bad for all these
things, so I kept them.
You guys want to see them?
Yes. Please come.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I only have five minutes.
I did bring them here, but.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Well,
we at the library appreciate
that you love preservation.
So.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: It's the
Library of Congress
that taught me it's not just
preservation, but everybody's --
Everything should be common
treasure for everybody.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
It was the Library of Congress
that I first learned the
word library in English.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
My inspiration and the desire to
preserve things came from the,
you know -- the books
about Library of Congress.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
That's why I respect
this place so much,
and this place is
special to my heart.
>> Anthony Dunn: See
how important we are.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 5: Thank you,
Library of Congress.
In Japanese, say -- Say
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: It's wonderful.
>> Speaker 5: I'm
not going to try.
Thank you.
>> Speaker 6: Hi, sir.
>> Speaker 2: All these
things I feel from my heart.
It took me 50 years, you know.
>> Anthony Dunn:
But you're here.
>> Speaker 6: Hi, sir.
I was wondering where could
we purchase your works
for the horror mystery stories.
I was very curious about that.
And I was wondering.
I have a DVD of "Castle
in the Sky" here
that I was hoping maybe I
could get a signature on.
If possible.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: There might
be Japanese bookstores
at [inaudible].
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
My dream is to have my books
translated in to English.
Books on animation, and
also the ghost stories.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Because it's, you know, a
collection of the Japanese soul
that I really want the people,
the English speaking
audience, to read.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Because I pour my heart and
soul in to everything I do.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I put my life in to it.
I want these, you know,
the "Castle and the Sky"
and the book about
"Totoro" that's coming
out to be accessible to
English speaking audiences.
Do you -- What do you think?
"Washington Post?"
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[ Applause ]
Of course I want them to be
in English, but if you want
to learn Japanese, they're in
-- This become like, you know,
a curriculum, that
would be great too.
It's a little bit hard, though.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Sure. Sure.
I can sign.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
They do have an autograph
session at Otakon, right?
He doesn't [inaudible].
Can I do this here?
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington:
We'll talk afterwards.
Yeah.
>> Speaker 2: He says
he can sign things
for you anywhere if you want.
>> Maureen Cohen
Harrington: Next question.
>> Anthony Dunn: Yeah.
>> Speaker 7: My question
is what do you think are the
qualities that make
a good story.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Speaker 2: The most important
thing is basic human emotions.
Not bad ones, but positive ones.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
[Inaudible] people who feel sad
to be doubtful about things,
to be in conflict
with other people.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
If it's just "The Avengers,"
you can't make a movie.
You need Thanos.
[ Laughter ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
You need, you know, the very
bad people to become, you know,
in conflict with somebody.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
But you need a straightforward
somebody with a true heart
of justice to be -- to
stand up against them.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
That heart does exist in the
very young, and the very old.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
He thinks it's very awesome
when an old man, you know,
can say thank you to a champion
of justice, but refuses to bow
down against the evil.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
I think that's a common
thread among all humanity.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Film is just, you know,
one medium of communicating
that kind of thing.
A panel is the same thing too.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
You know, if I don't give you
my heart, then you don't --
you think it's boring.
>> Hirokatsu Kihara: Enjoy?
>> Speaker 2: Have you
enjoyed this panel?
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington:
Thank you very much.
It was wonderful.
You are now part of the
Library of Congress.
This program is being webcast.
And you are now part
of our collections.
[ Applause ]
>> Maureen Cohen Harrington: And
thank you all for joining us.
We hope you enjoy
the other events.
the other events
that we're having
for anime for all.
And thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.